[Musique]
un peu de jazz ça fait toujours plaisir
voici agrandi au Nigeria nourri de
gospel et de chant traditionnels
débordant pour divers style musicaux
jazz pop et même le lyrique après un
périple aux États-Unis et en Angleterre
il vient poser ses valises ici à Orléans
alors rencontre avec Basset un artiste
qui a plus d'une corde vocale à son arc
moi j'aime bien
[Musique]
deux secondes pour Christophe comment il
est où passer moi je voulais voir
le boulot
tu nous viens du Nigéria et explique-moi
comment tu as rencontré la musique au
pays au bled comme on dit chez nous
c'est ma mec qui m'a amené à l'église et
si on est chanter la chorale et j'ai
beaucoup aimé c'est comme ça que j'ai
c'est quoi 56 ans 7 ans à 7 ans et j'ai
découvert la chorale
et je pense que trois ans après il avait
personne pour diriger cette chorale
c'est vraiment vrai en fait c'est pas
vrai moi 11 ans je chantais les
Chevaliers du Zodiaque
contre les forces des mondiales
garde toujours au fond de leur cœur le
sourire des vainqueurs
Jean-Christophe toi tu as commencé par
le jazz c'est ça carrément
Christophe toujours la classe il a
commencé par le jazz ensuite
conservatoire puis après le classique
c'est un peu ça l'idée exactement chez
moi chez mes parents il y avait beaucoup
de musique il y avait du jazz il y avait
du classique et puis après je suis
arrivé au lycée il y avait un big band
de jazz chercher un pianiste j'étais là
je suis rentré j'ai adoré on a fait
plein de concerts puis après bien pour
jouer du piano vraiment bien je suis
rentré aussi à fond dans le classique et
en allant conservatoire parle-moi un
petit peu de ce que tu ressens avec
Basset ben écoute ça fait deux ans qu'on
s'est rencontré à l'initiative de Basset
qui montait une nouvelle équipe sur son
projet on a bien kiffé la musique
ensemble il y a beaucoup de voix j'aime
beaucoup la voix c'est bien entendu et
aussi avec les autres membres de
l'équipe et c'est parti quoi est-ce que
je peux vous écouter faire un truc on va
en profiter avec les téléspectateurs là
je fais ce que je peux mais en tout cas
voilà je vous suis moi
[Musique]
love
et j'adore ça
[Musique]
et comme un bébé
moi aussi j'adore avoir
[Musique]
Jean-Christophe